FOLLOW THOSE.
SO I ASSUME THEY SENT SOME KIND
OF REPORT TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND THERE WILL BE SOME
PROCESS AND HOPEFULLY DUE
PROCESS BUT I HAVE FRANKLY NO
IDEA BECAUSE THIS HAS CHANGED
THROUGHOUT, THEY WERE ALREADY
DOING DEPOSITIONS AND THEN THEY
HOLD A VOTE WHICH THEY COULDN'T
KEEP ALL THEIR MEMBERS IN LINE
FOR, SO WE WILL HAVE TO SEE WHAT
THEY HAVE IN STORE FOR US NEXT.
>> Bret: WILL YOU MOVE OVER TO
JUDICIARY TO DO THAT?
>> WHEN THE LEADER PUT ME IN
INTEL, I AM STILL ON THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
>> Bret: SO YOUR GUESS IS IT'S
GOING TO COME TO AN IMPEACHMENT
VOTE BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR.
>> I DO THINK THAT'S THE PATH
THEY ARE ON BUT AGAIN, YOU NEVER
KNOW WITH THESE GUYS.
THIS WAS THE MOST UNFAIR PROCESS
I'VE EVER SEEN.
WE WEREN'T ALLOWED TO CALL THE
WITNESSES THAT WE WANT, THE ONES
WE WANTED THEY IGNORED.
EVEN TODAY THEY HAVEN'T RELEASED
ALL THE DEPOSITIONS SO THERE
WERE CERTAIN TESTIMONY GIVEN IN
THESE DEPOSITIONS TAKEN IN THE
BUNKER OF THE BASEMENT OF THE
CAPITAL WE COULDN'T USE AN OPEN
HEARING.
SO WE WILL HAVE TO SEE BUT I
ANTICIPATE, THAT'S MY BEST
GUESS.
>> Bret: TODAY, DAVID HOLMES
WAS THERE, TO TESTIFY ABOUT THIS
PHONE CALL BETWEEN AMBASSADOR
SONDLAND AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
TAKE A LISTEN, AMBASSADOR TAYLOR
AND THEN YOUR QUESTION.
>> THE MEMBER OF MY STAFF ASKED
AMBASSADOR SONDLAND WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP THOUGHT ABOUT
UKRAINE.
MR. SONDLAND RESPONDED THAT
TRUMP CARES MORE ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATIONS OF BIOTIN.
>> WHY DIDN'T YOUR BOSS BRING UP
THE CALL?
>> ARE REFERRED TO THAT CALL, HE
NODDED KNOWINGLY AS THOUGH HE
HAD BEEN BRIEFED ON IT.
>> I ASKED WHY HE DIDN'T SHARE
IT WITH US.
>> EVERYONE IS NODDING, OF
COURSE THAT IS WHAT'S GOING ON.
OF COURSE THE PRESIDENT IS
PRESSING FOR A BITE AN
INVESTIGATION.
>> Bret: YOU GO DOWN THAT ROAD
AND GET TO THIS POINT WHERE A
LOT OF THE WITNESSES SAID THEY
CAME TO THE CONCLUSION IN
COURTING AMBASSADOR SONDLAND,
100% BY SEPTEMBER 8TH THAT THE
AID WAS TIED TO THE
INVESTIGATIONS OF BURISMA AND
BIDEN IN 2016.
>> MR. SONDLAND SAID THERE WAS
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT NEEDED TO BE
MADE BY PRESIDENT ZELENSKY THAT
THEY WOULD DO AN INVESTIGATION
INTO BURISMA AND THE BIDENS AND
THAT IF THE ANNOUNCEMENT IS NOT
MADE, THEY DON'T GET THE CALL OR
THE MEETING ON THE MONEY.
AND THEY GOT THE CALL, THEY GOT
THE MEETING, THEY GOT THE
SECURITY ASSISTANCE DOLLARS AND
THERE WAS NEVER AN ANNOUNCEMENT
FOR PRESIDENT ZELENSKY OR ANYONE
ELSE IN UKRAINE AND THE
GOVERNMENT SO THIS IDEA THAT
THERE WAS A QUID PRO QUO DID NOT
HAPPEN, AND YET THEY CONTINUE TO
SAY THIS IS IMPEACHABLE.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THAT AT ALL.
THIS IS ABOUT THEY HAVE NEVER
ACCEPTED THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHEN 63 MILLION
AMERICANS IN AN ELECTORAL
COLLEGE LANDSLIDE SAID WE ARE
GOING TO SEND DONALD TRUMP TO
WASHINGTON AND SHAKE THAT TOWN
UP AND THE ESTABLISHMENT HAVE
NEVER ACCEPTED THAT AND THEY
WILL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES, FBI
INVESTIGATION, DOSSIER TO GET
HIM OUT, THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT.
>> Bret: ONE, DO YOU BUY THAT
THESE PROFESSIONALS DIDN'T TIE
BURISMA TO BIDEN?
ALL OF THESE GUYS SAYING VOLKER
AND SONDLAND, SECRETARY PERRY,
DIDN'T TIE THAT BURISMA HAD TO
DO WITH JOE BIDEN?
>> SOME OF THEM DID TIED TO THAT
>> SOME OF THEM DID TIED TO THA
THAT.
KURT VOLKER HAS A DISTINGUISHED
CAREER, SPECIAL ENVOY.
A DEFINITIVE NARRATIVE ON THE
SPIRIT HE WAS THE FIRST WITNESS
THAT ADAM SCHIFF CALLED AND YET
HIS TESTIMONY IS THE ONE THAT I
THINK BEST TELLS THIS ENTIRE
STORY, THIS ENTIRE EPISODE WHERE
THERE WAS NEVER A QUID PRO QUO,
THAT IT ULTIMATELY GOT
DELIVERED.
SOMETIMES THESE THINGS GET HELD
UP.
WE HEARD TESTIMONY FROM LOTS OF
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT THAT AS
WELL SO IT ALL WORKED OUT IN THE
END BUT A NEW GUY NEVER BEEN IN
POLITICS WHAT WE'VE GOT, NEVER
NEVER BET ON POLITICS AND WANTED
TO CHECK HIM OUT AND PEOPLE DEAD
BUT THE 55 DAYS AT THE AID WAS
HELD, THE VICE PRESIDENT
AMBASSADOR BOLTON, WENT THERE
AND MET WITH THIS GUY AND THEY
ALL COME BACK AND SAID THIS, HE
IS THE REAL DEAL, REFORMER,
RELEASED THE DOLLARS THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
EXACTLY WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DI
DID.
>> Bret: AMBASSADOR SONDLAND
CALLS PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
PRESIDENT HAS MESSED REFERENCED
IT MANY TIMES, I WANT NOTHING,
NO QUID PRO QUO.
AT THE SAME TIME, THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE LAUNCHES
THIS INVESTIGATION BASED ON THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WE DON'T SEE A COINCIDENCE THEY
ARE?
>> I DON'T BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE MET WITH
THIS GUY, HE HAD THE REFORMS
THEY DID IN THEIR PARLIAMENT
WHERE THEY STARTED THIS
CORRUPTION COURT WHAT THEY GOT
RID OF THE FORMER PROSECUTOR.
THERE WERE REFORMS THAT WERE
NEEDED AND YOU HAD A PRESIDENT,
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT A BIG FAN OF
FOREIGN AID IN THE FIRST PLACE,
HE WANTS EUROPEAN COUNTRIES TO
SHARE MORE OF THE BURDEN.
HE UNDERSTOOD THE CORRUPTION
PROBLEM AND SAID UKRAINE IS ONE
OF THE THREE MOST CORRUPT
COUNTRIES ON THE PLANET, PLUS HE
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT INFLUENCE OF
THE 2016 ELECTION AND THINGS
UKRAINIAN POLITICIANS WERE DOING
TO PERSUADE.
ALL THAT PACKAGE AND SAID BY THE
WAY, YOU'VE GOT A NEW PRESIDENT
SO HE SAID LET'S CHECK THIS GUY
OUT AND EVERYONE CAME BACK AND
SAID.
>> Bret: WHEN YOU HEAR
DEMOCRATS SAY IF IT IS ALL ON
THE UP AND UP, WHY DON'T YOU
GIVE US MICK MULVANEY AND
JOHN BOLTON, WHY DON'T YOU
RELEASE THE DOCUMENTS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ON THE
STATE DEPARTMENT TO COMPLETE THE
PICTURE IF IT IS ALL ON THE UP
AND UP?
>> WHAT I SAID YESTERDAY AS IF
IT WAS A FAIR PROCESS, THEN YOU
CAN ASK US THAT QUESTION BUT
UNTIL THIS PROCESS HAS A
SEMBLANCE OF FAIRNESS OR DUE
PROCESS FOR THE MINORITY AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES,
UNTIL WE GET TO THAT, WHEN WE
GET THOSE THINGS DONE MAYBE WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THAT BUT THAT IS
THE WHITE HOUSE IS CALLED.
I SEE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE
HOW UNFAIR THIS HAS BEEN
THROUGHOUT.
>> Bret: YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT WILL BE IMPEACHED?
>> THEY'VE GOT THE NUMBERS BUT
WAS MOST TELLING ABOUT THAT VOTE
A FEW WEEKS AGO AS TWO DEMOCRATS
CAME OVER TO OUR SIDE.
IT DOESN'T LOOK PROMISING.
BASED ON THE WHISTLE-BLOWER,
SEEING WHAT HIS MOTIVATION WAS
FOR STARTING THIS WHOLE THING.
THAT IS THE PART THAT BOTHERS SO
MANY AMERICANS AND WHY THEY KNOW
INSTINCTIVELY THIS IS UNFAIR.
>> Bret: YORK COLLEAGUE ON THE
COMMITTEE SAID HE DIDN'T LIKE
THE CALL, HE THOUGHT IT WAS
INAPPROPRIATE.
CAN YOU GET THERE?
>> NO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS HIS OWN WAY
OF CONDUCTING BUSINESS.
I LIKE THE WAY HE OPERATES.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE LIKE
A GUY WHO COMES HERE AND IS
SHAKING THIS TOWN UP AND AGAIN
AS I SAID, THE FACTS ARE ON THE
PRESIDENT SIDE AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE SAID THIS HAS BEEN
TOTALLY UNFAIR.
>> Bret: TWITTER QUESTION,
HAVE YOU EVER WORN A JACKET?
>> I HAVE.
YOU HAVE TO WEAR ONE ON THE
HOUSE FLOOR AND I ALWAYS DO WHEN
I'M AROUND THE PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CHAIR
LINDSEY GRAHAM SAYS THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INSPECTOR GENERAL
WILL RELEASE HIS REPORT ON THE
ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
PROBE IDENTIFIES AND
SPECIFICALLY DECEMBER 9TH.
THAT IS TWO DAYS BEFORE
MICHAEL HOROWITZ IS SCHEDULED TO